going on here this is obviously Pramod
and uh we're gonna close it out with one
last King under sting it leo brendan
king of the sting high school
sweethearts getting married Oh bang bang
bust nuts a little more classy around
the broad bro look at the how old is
this kid high school sweethearts and
then there's sixteen yeah young [ __ ]
it's a good question man you know
there's times where I feel like I wish I
would have gotten married when I was in
high school or something specially these
days doesn't really work out just
thinking out they wouldn't think how
much of a dumb ass you were at 16 you
grow so even now think four years ago
you grow so much a different person then
I guess hopefully guys grow together
major and different [ __ ] I was in a
transformers on 16 I'm gonna [ __ ] about
transformers now you feel me mm-hmm I
like I did only black girls when I was
16 yeah I would still do it now yeah
young fan matters man you know high
school sweethearts is tough man would
you do what Chappelle would you've gone
back to high school and got married your
high school sweetheart my first
girlfriend was [ __ ] two years oh yeah
how's that going great going great man
what do they call it once your first
girlfriend you get married when you're
[ __ ] 2013 why didn't you ever have a
girlfriend before that's a reservoir
anger bro he didn't in 1.0 you know
that's a red flag though you know but
think of peanuts you dress like but
think about if when you got married
when you had all those anger issues
you're a different person now right you
have to work on your wing you have to
work on yourself brace obviously save
it's best that I never was in a
relationship cuz I was yeah I was just
so crazy
you know hey cat you dated homeboy for
never yeah
damn near 10 years from high school yeah
I was with him from the time I was 14
until I was twenty four and three got
married just be bored you just at one
point you just friends yes absolutely at
one point your friend your roommate
mm-hmm but if you don't like a boyfriend
then that's where it kind of falls off
you know I think that's fine if you guys
are just like good friends at that point
I think a lot of marriages kind of end
up that way anyways yeah if you felt
like a good friend then you can get
married oh yeah it's interesting you
know if you'd have gone back in time
chan what would happen if he got married
your high school girlfriend about that
little one that was on your lap and
you're 300 pounds Labradoodle I don't
know I do be remember having like a
really big crush and she was course it
was it was really that could be your
wrestling name big crush and you just
drink orange soda on the side but I'm
glad I didn't actually hook up with some
of the crushes because like I got to be
friends with afterwards and realize oh
well we were not really made for each
other
amen yeah so yeah no I wouldn't not high
school Nick nah man I talked about I
peaked in middle school a long dry spell
in high school so there there was no
sweethearts I had a great high school I
just wasn't getting it sound sad women
you're snowboarding in your backyard
gambling addiction I remember it fondly
[Laughter]
call it a week before graduation damn
right I forgot that no any secretly
records I can go cuz I can watch a video
later hoping one of us smelled it look
this is where they find my underwear I'm
super industry she rubs her feet on so I
can sell this [ __ ] cinesín or underwear
did you told me she was gonna send in
the update and then she said she would
and I haven't seen it you talk about you
talk about streaks yes
streaks my thanks are us yeah I think
the default has become streaks even
though we all ripped out
[Laughter]
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]